really go and take my seat and raise my
non-germain Amendment
um and vice chairman bone will lead us
and then at 10 at 270 and then at 10
I'll take the chair back and we'll do
sp7 271 so I'll see everybody right over
there
okay I don't know why we that's not with
us I'm sure our researchers will get it
to us soon
um I'm gonna introduce the let me read
the number here
um
a little disjointed today the kid was up
at 2 A.M
a little yeah so I'm like I'm I'm I'm
waking up I'm just not there yet oh and
then it was a two meetings this morning
and my brain is just uh it's just not
where it should be let me grab hold on
number
I don't have it okay okay
all right here we go all right so uh
introduce Amendment 2023
1362 H
which we've seen before we retained um
it moves the primary date to June
um so to just kind of give the
background about why I'm doing this it
is not about moving the primary date to
June I'm open to conversations about
what day to move it to I am a publicly
supporter of June but I have voted for
August I would support May I'd support
basically anything that's not where it
is now that's not moving it back just
one week
um the we when we retained the original
bill that came we submitted the
committee uh the idea was the Senate
would act uh and then the Senate does
what the Senate does and did not act and
very opposed to changing the primary
date in the year that the primary is
happening that's kind of the no-go we've
traditionally in this body not made
substantive changes to election law that
applied to the election that was
immediately happening that year
um
and there's numerous examples of that
sp418 with the affidavit ballots we
pushed off till after the election
um so
um this is an attempt to keep this alive
I'm happy to answer any questions about
you know why we need to move it
um I'm definitely going to be excited to
hear
um where people think it should be but
not stuck on June I'm not against August
I just we just need something to keep it
alive because the Senate has not done
their job and per usual that means the
house has to do the work so it's a long
shot but you miss every shot you don't
I have any questions represent Kennedy
hi Ross uh what what are your main
reasons for wanting to move it earlier
yeah um so it's very simple
um
let's take our let's take this last
election which happened about six weeks
before the general election so let's
let's put the election into a timeline
right so we file in June yay that's the
official beginning of an election
I take issue with that with that excuse
me excuse me I take issue with that
notion to begin with because the concept
that somebody running for governor is
going to wait till June to start is
laughable
um I will note that the nominee for U.S
Senate for the Republican party in 2020
started running I'm sorry in 2022
started running three days after uh his
loss of 2020. so they don't wait
um this concept that there's this magic
date that they wait is is kind of
ludicrous to begin with but when you
take it into Concepts right so let's say
let's say we have a hypothetical
situation where we have an incumbent
Governor
um so that incumbent Governor is
probably not going to be primary if they
are primaried it's going to be nominal
at best we've seen that in late and the
incumbent Governor always gets over 80
85 percent of the vote the primary is a
joke so what does that incumbent end up
doing well incumbent ends up spending
that entire period campaigning to the
general electorate right so they're
talking to the voters that they need to
win which is more voters versus let's
say the other party has a primary well
there's an expression in politics you
have to win game six to get to game
seven right
so does that does that other
um party get to campaign to the general
electorate no they have to campaign to
their primary base all the way until
September so there's a couple of things
that happens with that you can make
Arguments for against about candidates
running to their various bases
um and the pivot but the reality is it's
an inherent uh it's inherently a
disadvantage that the
non-incumbent gets to campaign to the
general electorate for six weeks and the
incumbent gets to campaign to the
general electorate for six months so
let's put things in but let's go further
into a timeline here right when do we
send out absentee ballots
we send out absentee ballots the first
absentee pallets go out 45 days before
the election you will kava goes out 45
9 45.
all right
this
um we continue
um
so 45 days for the election the absentee
ballots go out right so let's put this
into a timeline so that means that the
first five days before the election
right because you
your covers your Carver ballots are
emailed right so they literally get them
instantly so they fill them out they
drop them in the mail so 45 days out the
first votes in New Hampshire are being
cast
the primary was decided two weeks before
that at best two weeks so if you are a
general if you are a non-incumbent
candidate you've had two weeks to
campaign to that general election voter
two weeks
so does anybody here truly believe that
in two weeks you can go from running a
primary campaign to a general electric
and campaign when votes are starting in
two weeks so when you ask why do we
desperately need to move it we
definitely need to move it because two
weeks is not enough time to make your
pitch to the voters it's bad for
democracy that we have it that close
because both sides are not able to
actually deliver their message right
they hear the base here is one thing
right the General Electric here's
another
and you say they'll say it's not that
they'll change policy positions but the
messaging will be different right so if
you're running in a Republican primary
you might talk about things like you
know guns or your pro-life if you're
running in the Democrat primary you may
talk about how you are opposed you know
you want to pass gun restrictions and
you're pro-choice right and then you get
to the general electorate and you may
want to talk about taxes or you may want
to talk about you know parental rights
for protecting students whatever it is
that the base may like and the general
electorate may like but they're not
aligned right so the candidates the
candidates may not be not that they're
in disalignment but the the messaging is
different
um and two weeks to deliver a new
message or a message that more rounds
out the candidate
um is not
is not fair uh and also the thing I
would point out is there's no debates
right so you have those those General
Electric candidates are now unvetted so
people are voting on unvetted candidates
um the only debates that have been
taking place were debates on the primary
so once again they were debates to
issues of the debase and not issues that
concern to the general electorate as a
whole moving the primary date is so
important
um you know the the reason we we had the
late primary date was uh the late not
the previous Secretary of State Gardner
had this Vision
um if anybody kind of has worked with
them you knew he was obsessed with this
thing called the VAP VAP voter age
participation
he believed I believe wrongfully he
believed that the late primary was the
reason we had a high voter turnout a
high VAP turnout
in the general election
I fully disagree with that assessment
um having studied the American
electorate
for years that's what my degree is in
this is a statistical study of American
political Behavior
um
the late primary was not why New
Hampshire has high voter turnout New
Hampshire has high voter turnout because
number one we have hotly contested close
elections when people think their vote
matters when they think if their votes
might make the difference between
Canada a or candidate B they are far
more likely to vote
number two
education
this is one of the highest educated
states in the country
number three
income
the higher the income the more likely
somebody is to vote this is an upper
income State and the one that's
uncomfortable but is true is that white
if white voters tend to vote more than
voters of color and this is an 89 white
state so you take those four things
together race income education and
closely contested elections that makes
for a high turnout election
not having a late primary so for years
we had this late primary because that
was the mentality was that it was it was
turning up it was increasing voter
turnout
um it's based on nothing
um there are states that have you know
every year we get that thing from the
Secretary of State about the VAP in New
Hampshire is always in the top three
right like Wisconsin's up there or
whatever it literally has nothing like
you look at those other states their
primary is not in September
yet they have high voter turnout because
they have similar characteristics so we
need to move it um just to kind of wrap
all this up we need to move that I'm not
stuck on June I'm definitely open to
other dates I have voted for August in
the past but this is our last
opportunity to try to get this done this
year
um because basically we don't do it now
um I can't support moving the primary
date inside the election window and we'd
have to do something like Kick the Can
down for another two years and I really
um I really don't think we should wait
thank you
uh so can you tell me when those other
primaries are in the top three prime uh
states with voter um participation uh
not the top of my head but I I can tell
you where we rank in the country so we
rank last
um we are last and the last primary go
um Us in Rhode Island sometimes Rhode
Island will like be really if you want
to model New Hampshire after Rhode
Island go for it but
um sometimes new
um rental go after us but usually it's
us in Rhode Island or the last
um August and June kind of puts us in
the middle May has been thrown out there
and at that point like even I start
getting uncomfortable like maze kind of
early there are states
um Tech conduct their Primary in the odd
year I would never recommend that
um that's probably on the other end of
the extreme uh the states that have a
primary in December of the odd year
which is kind of wild but it just kind
of shows you how late we are right that
we're doing it six weeks before the
general election and there are states
that are like no we don't even do it in
the year
yes follow
-up so I would really like to know those
those primary months that those other
states that have high turnout have
um
when you're saying also this is the
follow-up uh to vote for this even
though it's June if you're more inclined
to say August this would get get you
there if if we is that what you're
saying yeah so open to amendments oh I'm
I'm definitely open to this my my point
of the amendment is to keep the
discussion alive I did make a mistake in
that I thought that the underlying bill
was a unanimous Bill and it turns out it
was a partisan bill so I I am toying in
my head I told you guys I do not want to
recess a bill I am toying in my head
with recessing the bill to have the
amendment replace the entire bill just
to make the conversation easier
um but that's a conversation we'll have
during exec
um if there's zero interest then I'm
just uh you know I'm just uh chasing a
ghost here then we'll just move on
um that's okay some you don't win them
all but it's a
we have to keep it alive I needed
something to keep it alive and I got
this amendment in with two minutes to
spare so it wasn't I didn't have a whole
lot of time to uh call around and say
hey what do you want to do
uh representative thank you Mr chair
um we have retained a bill on this
correct correct okay follow up follow up
and can you explain one more time why
you don't want to just work on that
retained billing because I want to get
the date change for the next election
and we cannot touch that retained Bill
until January
um so I do not want to change the 2024
election
in the year 2024. if we're going to
change the 2024 election once again to
be fair to the candidates right and our
voters by the way
we need to change it in 2023.
um so you know the
the alternative plans would be to bring
that retained Bill back and pump it back
to 2026.
um but you know the we've been talking
about this now for a long time
um and we just need to keep the
conversation alive and like I said I
will talk about during exec but I am
totally open to ideas to keep it alive
in 2023 because once it gets to 2024
um it's going to become much more of an
representative brand
Mr chair
my question
um am I understanding your testimony
correctly to be that one of the main
reasons for
um your Amendment and moving the primary
date is to accommodate candidates who
are unable to Pivot their messaging from
the primary to the general election and
is that
um
a legitimate reason to move it you know
all candidates pivot all of them both
parties pivot you can't do it in two
weeks so if you have an incumbent right
I am not into protecting incumbents I've
said that many times I consider our
current primary the incumbent protection
plan right so the incumbent gets to
message to the general electorate for
six months and the Challenger gets the
message to the general electorate
ostensibly for two weeks because voting
starts two weeks after their primary
so even if the incumbent the incumbent
gets to run a general election strategy
from the beginning
Challengers
have to run a primary strategy once
again gotta win game six to get to game
seven
and then they have two weeks to try to
make a pitch to general election voters
they're not even communicating it's not
that you're I understand you're probably
thinking about the message I'm more
thinking about who the message is going
to
if you're in a primary and you're
sending mail you're not going to send
mail to the general electorate the
general electorate is five times the
size of the primary electorate you're
going to send mail to the primary
electorate so the only voter is getting
a getting an input or getting receiving
information from the fam from the
candidates are primary voters
General Electric voters should be
campaigned to as well and they should
have longer than two weeks to make their
decision
follow up please follow up is there
anything in current statute that would
prevent a candidate from doing voter
Outreach by retail campaigning by door
knocking by spreading their message
before the primary and
is there anything in statute that would
prevent a candidate from using a
consistent message through their retail
perhaps start before the general
campaign period for the primary yeah
absolutely so the first is campaign
Finance laws
which are you don't have access to your
general election money until six weeks
for the general election
so the general election candidate gets
to spend their primary money on the
general electorate and the primary
candidate gets to spend they get they
get to spend so the general election can
the incumbent can spend their primary
money on the general electorate starting
whenever they want technically June
whenever they want
um the primary candidate doesn't give
doesn't have that luxury they have to
spend their primary dollars on the
primary electric because they need the
primary electorate to win so I will uh
I'll kind of answer your question with a
question you're in a contested primary
race let's say you and I are in the same
party and we're in a contested primary
race it'd be an interesting primary
that's for sure
um
I spend my entire time talking to the
primary electorate
and you spend your entire time doing
what you just inferred which is
messaging to everybody
we go into that primary
I'm going to smoke you in the primary
because I have campaigned to the voters
that vote in that primary and you have
campaigned to voters that have not
campaigned do not vote in that primary
because when you go and vote in the
general electorate right the General
Electric is about five times the size
of the primary electorate so you're
going to spend your limited resources
four out of five of which are going to
go to voters who are not going to vote
not going to say they're not going to
vote for you they're just not going to
vote I'm going to spend my resources
going with the voters that vote and
we'll see who wins it's going to be me
the situation from diverse it was you if
I was so foolish as to campaign to the
general electorate in the primary and we
were primary and you went to the primary
voters you would smoke me
and we'd all sit back and they would say
why did he do that and he'd be like well
he wanted to win the general but once
again you can't win the game six to get
to game seven you have to win the game
six game six in front of game seven
so to answer your question structurally
it's money
structurally they have to spend their
primary dollars on the primary
electorate
versus the income that can spend their
their primary dollars on the General
Electric it's a luxury that is granted
to the incumbent because the late
primary is the incumbent protection plan
representative Howard
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh so we're talking
about two weeks here from when people
are uh finishing up with the primary and
when they're getting their absentee
balance and when we're looking at this
are these people filling out their
absentee ballots as soon as they get
them
they they certainly can it's a it's it's
me it's sent to them electronically um I
voted with an absentee about four and I
I don't get it and let it sit on my desk
um but I once again I think you should
you should have the right to vet your
candidates right you should have the
right to have your candidates campaign
to you right I think that that's an
important part of it I actually think
candidates going out and spreading their
message is an important part of the
democratic process
um versus just you reading something on
a blog or something it takes a while I
mean I used to work in campaigns
thankfully I don't anymore
um it takes a while to make that pivot
you come off of primary night you are
tired you've been you're up till like
two o'clock in the morning because towns
like Salem don't report till 1am right
so the next day is dead so now you're at
13 days right then you have to sit
around and figure out is there going to
be a recount right God forbid there's a
recount by the way because if there's a
recount that two-week window is gone
the moment we have a Statewide recount
in this state for a primary which we
could have had in 2016 when Franco blue
lost by 808 votes
the two-week window that I've just
described to you is gone it will take
more than two weeks to conduct a
Statewide primary recount
so
the the time window is too compressed
it's too compressed and
even you can make the argument you know
two weeks is aggressive I'd still say
six weeks is not enough
six weeks not enough to craft a message
right message test figure out what's
going on and go out and campaign the
other member talked about knocking on
doors how many doors can you knock on in
six weeks if you're in a Statewide race
hello
thank you uh
somebody
success in the primary uh blowing out
all their opponents and um they they end
up uh oh thank you thank you
um and and uh
that that individual ends up
having an uncontested uh or you know
their opponent has an uncontested
primary uh when that happens
what are I guess what what are what are
the voters thinking when they have to
now decide between potentially two uh
candidates who haven't served an office
before they have the same time to reach
people don't they yeah so I think to get
to your underlying question
um there's no accounting for working the
party process right so if if one
candidate can suspect can successfully
convince every member of their party not
to challenge them moving the date
doesn't change that at all right because
if that happens in June right to if on
our existing law if that happened in
June right the incumbent the incumbent
Advantage it still exists but it's now
greatly diminished there's no moving the
date that fixes that
um we do know that that happens very
rarely
um it's very rare that that
open seats are not open seats that are
winnable in the general
are very often not are very often
primary right the seats that you see
that don't have primary tend to be ones
that are unwinnable for the respective
party right so if you know an example is
there was a state senate race in Salem
right this is the most Republican seat
in the state there was no contested
primary for uh the Democratic party
because they all knew the candidate was
going to lose by two two to three uh two
to one and they lost by two to one so
nobody wanted to throw it in there but
when there's a contest right when that
that end goal is winnable there's almost
always a primary so in that same seat I
just referenced there was a primary
right it was an open seat but there was
a primary on the Republican side because
it was a winnable Republican seat so but
to go back to your underlying question
there is no moving the date will not
change a candidate's ability to work
their own party
um but you know
you can make some philosophical
statements about are you circumventing
the will of the people at that point
right you know who who's really in
control that's a deeper conversation for
a deeper day but to your underlying
Point moving the date will not change
someone's a person's ability to meander
their own party
any further questions ah I'm
representative about Bruno Mars thank
you Mr chairman
do you think this would be helpful for
college students to register to vote and
uh get absentee ballots prior to leaving
for college I know that's
seems to have been a challenge in my
community watching people do that and
then also try to move to college at this
around the same time yeah I I don't know
if it would be the one of the objections
of July
is that people are out of the state I
don't know by I don't know anybody
leaves New Hampshire in July it's the
best month to be here but
um
especially here's over there
but I I don't think I don't think it
would
keeping it in June you're still in the
college student window right so I mean I
do hold a different view than many of my
colleagues on my side of the aisle about
college students I think they do have a
legal right to vote here
um however
um I think they're most of them are
still around in June they can sell their
absentee ballots they can definitely go
get those absolute belts in person in
May
um but the um you know in terms of in
terms of absentee voting the one thing
that it would and and this would be true
for August or any date we moved one
thing I would do is it would relieve our
uokava pressures that we have uh and it
would negate the argument of like what
happens if we have a Statewide recount
um one of these days we are going to
have a Statewide recount it is going to
happen and we are going to miss that
yokava date and we're going to get sued
and then we're going to have to move it
because the Court's going to tell us we
have to move it like that's coming down
the line by the way
um it I don't know when it will happen I
can't tell you if it'll happen in 2024
if it'll have a 2026 but my my smart
money is on it happens in the next
decade so moving the day would help with
absentee ballots at a minimum because
the Secretary of State's office wouldn't
be drinking from a fire hydrant trying
to get those things out they'd have a
lot more time to get those things out
for the for the general election for the
primary election I mean they have it's
this the windows the same that they have
now they know who's running they have
time to print it up and there's hardly
ever any issues with absentee ballots in
the primary the absentee ballot issues
which are very limited uh tend to arise
in the general just just because things
are moving so fast
because we have six weeks okay any
further questions
with that
thank you and I don't see anybody
wanting to testify so with that I'll
close the hearing on the amendment on
271.
all right and I'm back
thank you to representative aikenberg
for giving me a call for Los Angeles
um I'm gonna we've closed the hearing on
um the non-germaine amendment 2023 1362
h
up to SB 271 and now we're gonna
actually hear SB 271
um we get to hear this today because we
didn't take possession of the bill in
time for last week
um so
do we have this anyone from the Senate
here to introduce this bill
oh Senator Brad oh wow we have not only
do we have anyone we have the Senate
President
foreign
welcome to uh do we call you Senator or
president
good morning
um Mr chairman members of the committee
for the record Jeff Bradley from
Wolfeboro
um I thought this was a pretty simple
bill
designed to protect the New Hampshire
primary I see suddenly that it may not
be so simple but
um we'll just discuss
the intent of the bill which the Senate
did pass it
um a man's RSA 6535 delegates to the
National Convention and it adds a
sentence that any New Hampshire
delegates
that have been selected
shall be seated by the National
Convention and have full voting rights
that's it
pretty simple I think everybody knows
why
I would hope that we are all about
protecting the New Hampshire primary the
primary is going to happen
um there will be a republican nominee
there will be Democratic nominee there
will be delegates from New Hampshire and
at least in our our law they should have
full voting rights and should be seated
so that's why I introduced it and I
commend it to you
will you be taking questions Senator
sure are there questions from the
committee
uh I almost called you Center King uh
representative Kennedy not just quite
yet you got to talk to him though if you
want to do that I had to turn this on
first
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking my question uh I'm a new person
here so you said uh that we all know why
this was put in but I don't so could you
explain what happened what the problem
was really okay
so obviously the Democratic
the Democratic National Committee has
adopted rules that
in essence say New Hampshire is first in
the nation's status no longer will be
the case and anybody that campaigns here
the delegates from New Hampshire for
that person will be penalized and so my
view is and I think the view of the
Senate is
those delegates should be seated at the
National Convention
further questions from the committee
representative Lane
thank you Mr chair and thank you senator
practice our state law going to have on
the Democratic National Committee
I think it's probably not enforceable
but nevertheless I think it's important
for New Hampshire
to do everything that we can
to protect the first in the nation's
status
we're hearing from presidential
candidates in the Senate
we passed a resolution unanimously we've
even passed a constitutional amendment
that you folks will have an opportunity
to to consider to enshrine in our
constitution our first in the nation's
status this goes along with that even
though it may be difficult to enforce it
but nevertheless it is about
protecting to the extent we can in our
law that New Hampshire delegates should
be treated with the same respect and
appreciation that delegates from every
other state are treated
further questions from the committee
representative Muirhead thank you Mr
chair
um Senator what what are the enforcement
issues that you see that would make this
unenforceable
well
the Democratic National Committee is
meeting in Chicago
so I would presume that the state of
Illinois laws would apply there or
perhaps federal laws I think it would be
unenforceable as a result that being
said it's an important message that we
send
and it doesn't matter whether it's
Democrats or Republicans we're
protecting or trying to protect by
making a clear statement that delegates
should be seated and have full voting
rights
further questions representative weary
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so
um I'm just curious is that just trying
to think through the litigation that it
would likely result
and if the New Hampshire representatives
were not seated then they would be
infringing upon New Hampshire citizens
rights to have our votes considered in
that situation
so I'm I'm just trying to think through
the possible litigation do you do you
see something arising from that you know
they don't see our our delegates and
then what would happen in that
again I don't think it's enforceable
but I do think it's important
nevertheless
okay thank you for taking
further questions
um I I have a question
um it Senator I do share your um
concerns about being unenforceable
um
this bill was being crafted was there
considered something
um that is enforceable
um so for example uh I have a I take
issue with us telling a private
organization how to conduct their
business however we do control the
states for Electoral College votes so
has there any sort of thing like that
been considered
uh no I didn't consider that I think um
again this is really more about
trying to stand up under New Hampshire
law that we believe
our delegates should have full voting
rights and should be seated and in
essence trying to
create the climate if you will at the
whatever convention is whether democrat
or republican in this case it's a
democratic convention that
our delegates should be seated and by
sending that message that's
what this is about
thank you are there any questions for
the questions of the committee
thank you so much Senator it's always a
pleasure seeing you thank you
um we have one of the persons signed in
to speak for this uh Colin
turning
make sure you press that silver button
right there
awesome thank you Mr chairman thank you
honorable members of the committee
um I kind of um my name is Colin Tiernan
I'm representing myself I wanted to
speak on my experience as a delegate in
2016 and why I think this is a worthy
Bill even if it's not enforceable
there's still the Optics of it there's
still the reality of
um what delegates go through in 2016 I
experienced delegates spitting pushing
seat stealing they sent people to fill
seats there were lights turned off on
entire states there were white noise
machines there were a chance of USA USA
USA over no more Wars and you know I'm a
veteran I served in the Marine Corps I
was in Iraq I had a no more war sign
they took a giant American flag to cover
that up so it still irks me to this day
overall I think it was a pretty toxic
and traumatic experience and if nothing
else comes from this bill that the
opportunity for delegates to come back
here and talk to you all about about
their experience I think is is very
worthy
um I think that if the delegates are not
seated from New Hampshire that that
would be a problem for me personally as
an American and I hope it would be for
everyone here too so thank you for your
time and I'm open to any questions but
actually I I'm sure after statement like
that there will be questions at a
minimum I will have some uh are there
foreign
okay I guess I'll start off uh so I was
not a delegate but I was on the floor uh
we were probably at opposite conventions
um I I experienced some of that climate
uh what's called chaos uh it wasn't a
streamlined process on my side either
let's do that uh
uh so your interpretation of this bill
is that this would make sure that
basically they can't uh let's just say
it's enforce we'll put that aside for a
second uh this would basically make sure
that they can't silence you on the floor
as well is that one of the things you
you view in this bill I think it brings
transparency transparency to that whole
process right of of what happens to
delegates once they're there and one
thing I would maybe suggest that could
come out of this is having a
communication with your delegates
um afterwards what was their experience
like were they treated properly
um at convention I just I see a lot of
value here and it's I see a lot of need
because I don't think that tends to
happen
excellent all right any other questions
I don't know I hope you hang around
because I'd love to swap some stories
with you I think it would be fun sounds
good thank you so much
okay uh has anyone else signed up to
speak on SB 271
um seeing none uh representative can you
grab that blue sheet for me
and then we will
okay uh there is no one signed in to
speak uh there's no one signed up that
didn't speak uh so with that I will
close the hearing on SB 271 we're going
to take a 30 second pause or 10 second
pause
okay we are going to take a brief recess
uh sorry I was asking the ranking member
um if she wanted uh and representative
Grill the clerk
opinion is very important as well uh so
we will break uh how long do you think
you need ranking member
all right we're gonna break for 10
minutes
um
you guys want you guys want to stay in
here you want to go somewhere what yeah
you can go in there it's fine all right
so our College from the other side will
go in there
um and my colleagues from the right side
of the aisle see what it did there uh
we'll stay in here
foreign
okay it's 10 35. uh we've gotten all
back and I don't think anything changed
so classic government uh wasted time and
nothing changed
um
going to open the executive session uh
for the house election law committee
um first up on the docket is sb70
um
so I will move that SB 70 I hit the off
pass motion reverse so I only live the
sb70 be ought to pass I'll second that
Mr chairman thank you second in uh and
now I will introduce Amendment 2023
1280h so I'll make the motion to ought
representative boam we'll grab that
second
uh yep right can you read my handwriting
12 18h and now we are on discussion of
the amendment is there any discussion on
all right well that was riveting uh are
we ready to vote okay the clerk will
call the role on we are voting on the
amendment we're voting on the amendment
representative prudomo Brian
no
representative
bogert
yes
representative Burnham
no
representative Kennedy yes
representative weary yes
representative wood
no
and representative Barry yes so I'm not
no not last I'm dead last oh dead last
I'm dead last
yes
Ward
the payment yes
representative yes
representative nearhead yes
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes representative
Howard yes
and representative Barry coming back to
you yes twice so I'm going to count that
that is sweet 18 that is 15 EAS and
three Nays yep okay with that the
amendment carries uh just so everybody
knows I should have announced that the
very beginning case um
there will be no replacement for uh
representative Smith
um we got rid of the vacant seat so this
committee is now 99 so I should have
announced that at the very beginning but
for those scrambling trying to do math
we are now a 18 person committee so
closer to my dream of 13-person
committees
um but not we're still a little off okay
uh we are now on to discussion on the
underlying bill as amended sb70 as
all right this is riveting
all right with that the clerk will call
so this is for ought to pass as amended
and representative boom
oh uh well we are the we had a not to
pass motion to begin with
with the Remake the ox pass motion oh I
guess yeah we do have to do otpa yeah
yes thank you you are right you are
right I will make the motion of ought to
pass as amended can I get a second
all second all right we're on auto
passes admitted sp70.
representative
prudhome O'Brien yes
representative bogert
yes
Representative inkerberg no
representative Kennedy
no
representative weary
representative wood no
representative Lane
yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative mirrorhead yes
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes and representative Barry yes
right okay uh with that we will close
the executive session on SB 70 uh we'll
open the executive session on SB 156 I
recognize representative Boom for
emotion
I make a motion of itl on SB 156. is
there a second I'll second all right the
motion is on inexperienced legislate on
Senate Bill 156 is there discussion on
the motion yes uh representative mom you
recognize well my big problem with 156
is it allows the use of
public information
more private information depending on
you look at it to
um approved that somebody is real exists
or whatever and definitely I cannot go
along with that see somebody to go into
Facebook and whatnot and say yeah that
person is real because he's got a
Facebook account or that person is real
because he's using Tick Tock or whatever
and so that's my main reason for
um voting itl on this bill further
discussion on the itl motion yes
representative Brennan
thank you Mr chair
um I share my colleagues concerns about
privacy we
testimony from the prime sponsor Senator
gray that this would be a voluntary
program or voluntary exercise for voters
to
indicate that they would allow the
Secretary of State or town clerks or
supervisor the checklist to
um
use this non-public information and
in on page seven
line 25 it does say that the Secretary
of State shall prescribe an amendment to
the voter registration based on the
following
um and then goes on to line 27 the
Secretary of State May collect
additional voluntary non-public
information
um
and so I support what Senator Gray's
intention is in this bill to make it a
voluntary thing there is an issue
however in
um p on page 12 line 19
where it does not specify that the voter
would be voluntarily
providing this non-public information
um
this I feel like you're gonna ask a
question I'm sorry oh no no I can't
interrupt you while you're speaking a
that would be rude and B would be
outside of our rules that is true so um
Senator gray testified that the form
would be amended by the Secretary of
State to include a check box
um that would make it voluntary
I don't see in this bill that there is
That explicit instruction to the
Secretary of State in creating the new
form to
um
do what Senator gray intended
so
voting on this particular bill because I
do support what the intention is and I
would have to be putting my trust in the
Secretary of State to adjust the form to
put that check box in to make sure that
the privacy of our voters is not
violated without their explicit
um
approval of using the records that are
already in state systems to assist with
verifying the identity of their
registration which would ultimately
make it easier for voters to be properly
identified and verified and get their
registration
um
checked off
further comments from the committee
uh yes representative weary so if I
remember correctly there was a 2016
study that looked at
same-day registrants and tried to
analyze the data in terms of following
up you know did people actually
um
subsequent to that apply for New
Hampshire licenses and things like that
they found that the application rate was
something like
under it was under 25 percent and then
following up with those people there was
very little response back to the
Department of Motor Vehicles for that
um
for responding to that and and inquiring
and that so I I'm
suspect of
um
other means to create voter identities
that could be
uh
potentially
not in you know sort of not enforceable
or not not realized so I think I don't
know that this
um
solves any problems and I think it might
create some new ones so that's my
comment
further questions comments from the
committee
okay I have mine
um I share representative Brennan's uh
concerns maybe we look at it slightly
differently
um I look at this is that this could be
this non-public information that may be
used
um question I have is can it be used for
voter list purges in the future if we
don't find anybody on the rolls can we
then take them off because we have this
non-public information for those of you
who were paying attention last year that
was something that was proposed very
very similar to this bill in front of us
um so you know if you if you're into
that sort of deal this probably opens
the door for you to do that
um
but I know there's many members who are
not into voter list purchase so having
said that and no one else wanting to
comment to my comments I assume all
right then we will the clerk will call
the roll
representative O'Brien yes
representative bogert
yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative lean
no
representative word no
representative Hamer no
representative Hamlet no
representative Muirhead no
representative Bay no
no
representative Grill no representative
Howard no
and representative Barry yes
99 99 is there another motion that would
like to be made
that's interesting
did I throw you for a loop on that one I
did do you want it
would you uh would you like to retain
this bill
do you like to caucus and retain this
bill or would you like to I think
we should all right we will caucus I'm
going to give you okay never mind hope
she has taken she's taken her lead from
the honorary Vice chairman
representative beerhead the guy jumping
is there a second all right
representative Muirhead seconds
is there discussion on the retained
motion
um I don't speak to my motion
um
I think we all agree with the privacy
concerns and it gave us great pause on
what what drove us
in our caucus to vote for the bill was
the voter registration piece and
cleaning up this bill because taking out
all the stuff that has been ruled on
constitutional we are still concerned
about the privacy issues so I'd like to
retain it so we can address those and
perhaps work with the uh primary sponsor
to fix that language
uh further conversation on the bill
representative Bowman would like to be
recognized
you seem like you you're moving towards
the button so I figured you wanted to
say something okay
um
these new glasses I got the eagle eyes
um yes representative weary just had a
question is this the same uh thing that
the Supreme Court actually ruled on
after New Hampshire so New Hampshire
ruled some of this unconstitutional but
then the Supreme Court ruled on a
similar issue is that is this or am I
mixing up so yes and no
um so
um yes as all things in election laws
yes and no uh
so one of the one of the rulings uh in
sb3
um which was a three to two decision
from the New Hampshire Supreme Court was
that
um basically combating voter fraud was
not a enough of a compelling State
interest for the measures provided in
sb3 uh particularly the language in the
documents they had to sign the lengths
that we created in voting locations that
the
um
the state's interest in combating voter
fraud or perceived voter fraud whatever
you want to call it did not
did not didn't weigh enough to allow for
the provisions in sp3 the day before the
U.S Supreme Court uh in a decision I
think around North Carolina
um uh did said the exact opposite which
was the state does actually have a very
compelling interest in fighting uh voter
fraud even if it is perceived voting
fraud so I'm sure at some point our our
esteemed court system is going to have
to deal with that the the U.S Supreme
Court decision came out on a Thursday
the New Hampshire Supreme Court decision
came out the the Friday the the
literally the day afterwards on Friday I
know because I was going on to close up
on WMUR to talk about a supreme court a
U.S Supreme Court case and I got to talk
about New Hampshire stream court case I
hadn't read yet
um
so that's why it's in great that's why
the dates are ingrained in my memory
because it was awkward
um so I hope that sufficiently confused
you with the question that you asked
um
uh I I will be for for what since I'm
already talking I will be supporting the
retain motion
um these are I do have privacy concerns
issues uh I'm not necessarily against
cleaning our voter rolls I am against
using things like Facebook and Tick Tock
to clean our voter rolls uh so uh it's
kind of it's a once again it's one of
those uh it's election law so it's yes
and it's no so a retain is a great way
to yes and know this bill
it's like improv are there any other
comments questions concerns on the bill
all right seeing none the clerk will
call the role we are on uh the motion to
representative O'Brien yes
representative bogert
yes
representative inkerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative lean
yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Muirhead yes
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes representative
Howard yes representative Barry yes
18 To None okay and with that house bill
156 is retained I'll be closing the
executive session on house 156 will be
opening the executive session for one SB
157 I'll recognize representative Lane
to make a motion
I would like to make a motion ought to
pass
I will second that motion
and then represent Lane you were
recognized again I
would like to submit an amendment which
I think all of you should have copies of
2023-1385 h
and I will second that motion we are now
on discussion on the amendment uh 2023
1385 H is there discussion on the
amendment
[Music]
such as the reference only to accuvote
machines we've expanded the number of
places to uh to eight Wards instead of
four
we've also gone to uh only having
instead of basing the number of ballots
on a percentage we've done a hundred
ballots and uh per location and I'm
but those were the changes that were
made they're based on the questions that
the even though I wasn't here I did
watch the tape and I I based it on the
questions
um that came from the um from our
committee and that were and then worked
with some of the folks who made those
suggestions to draft this this amendment
further comments or questions on the
amendment representative Bowen you
recognized yeah I agree with uh
representative Lane thing on from the
hearing last week with and I I brought
this up too why just stack you vote
machines when we're going to be changing
them and we have to come up with another
bill to do it again so yeah I agree with
with the amendment
further discussion on the amendment
seeing none the clerk will call the role
the vote is to pass is to pass the
amendment of s of oh my God uh past the
amendment of uh 2023 1385 h on to SB
157.
representative booger yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative lean
yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer
yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Muirhead yes
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes representative
Howard yes
representative Barry yes
18 to zero we did it
um
representative Lane would you like to
make a motion of octopass as amended
yes please ought to pass is amended all
right we uh and I will second it uh so
we are now on discussion on ought to
pass an amendment on SB
157 as as amended
I probably stuttered through those words
real bad I'm having a day
okay all right
uh seeing no discussion the clerk will
call the roll
representative boom yes
representative purdom O'Brien yes
representative bogert
yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative lean yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative beerhead
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes representative
Howard yes
and representative Barry yes
18 to zero okay and with that uh SB 157
it will be sent out of committee as
ought to pass as amended uh
uh oh yes consent calendar
um would anybody like to make the motion
to put it on consent calendar as
representative so moves uh it was
anybody opposed to that bill going on
consent counter all right seeing none
they will go on consent calendar
where all bills should go
irregardless of the first one will not
um all right I'm going to close the
hearing on Senate Bill 157 and open the
um
here the executive session on Senate
bill 158.
representative
Burnham is recognized for a motion
thank you Mr chairman yes I'd like to
make a motion to itl SB 158. is there a
second second please there is a second
is there discussion on the motion of
inexpecting to legislate on Senate bill
158.
Mr bro you made the motion go first
um I just wanted to make a couple
comments
um being involved in my local elections
over the last 10 years I can understand
especially in 2020 the concern of time
and opening absentee ballots however
there are other
um officials there that are able to
assist in opening that outer envelope
um by allowing the town clerk to have
the opportunity to open that outer
Envelope as it's mailed in just leaves a
lot of room for suspicion
and I I end out in the Integrity of the
absentee ballots
um
and
and also
the process of someone handing in an
absentee ballot without
the outer envelope also raises concern
because then
other people may see that that is an
absentee ballot and it's not protected
by an outer envelope so to me um I just
just in order to save time I don't
believe is enough of a reason to
unprotect the absentee ballots by
removing those outer envelopes ahead of
time
representative Lane
thank you I'll be voting again a guest
emotion for itl but I do want to
highlight the fact that when Senator
gray spoke to us he stated that this
bill would fix both of the issues that
were raised in the court order that
necessitated this bill and I am not sure
that I agree with Senator gray in fact
when I I don't think it really addresses
the signature verification piece of it
and it's in section five of the bill
um it doesn't substantially change the
existing statute so I want to go on
record that it does not address at least
for those of us who will be voting for
the bill this does not address the
signature verification verification
process that's set out in the court
order
further discussion on the bill
on the inexpensely motion yes
representative Kennedy
uh am I mistaken or this is not specify
when the envelope can be opened
that was going to be a point that I was
going to raise
is there any further discussion before I
guess that that's kind of a nice part of
being chair you kind of get like the
last Salvo
all right
um
so let me discuss my issues with this
bill uh representative Kennedy's Point
we've heard pre-processing bills before
and they've always been done inside of a
window right noticed there was a notice
window and you could go and you could
show up and you could watch the ballots
be take it out of their outer envelope
and mark off the checklist
um and that was a transparent process
that was allowed to take place it was
noticed
um it was noticed we did when they had
these changes during covet it was notice
you could go in you could watch it uh
pre-processing bills that we've this
committee has dealt with before all had
a time and a date for that right so it
was like three days before the election
the week before the election whatever
this bill does not provide for that this
bill says those things are getting
opened as they come in so we lose that
transparent process I don't know why
that is done if the point is to speed
things up on Election Day you could
easily have put a window in there that
has been done before it seems like it
was
um almost intentionally left out my
second point to push back on my
colleague the ranking members statements
this does open the door for signature
verification and in fact if you listen
to the testimony uh the senator the the
bill sponsor said that the Secretary of
State office will provide training for
signature verification and that by
removing the word shell you have changed
the language of the statute the state
spent three million dollars defending
sb3 I imagine that we will see something
like that with that language change but
by changing that language we are
touching the language around signature
verification and with the testimony
given about training for signature
verification this bill will allow for
signature verification it will not be
compulsory because the word shall is
being removed but it will be an option
so if you're voting for this you will be
supporting a form of signature
verification because that is what the
sponsor of the bill said and by changing
that language that is clearly their
intent
um so I guess there's once again
election law there's things you like and
things you don't like I don't like that
the absc ballots are going to be opened
up before election day I don't think
it's necessary I definitely don't like
that there's not a definitive window for
that but I do like that we're going to
go back to some signature verification
and if those things are not signed
correctly uh it looks like I guess
they'll have a chance to fix them but uh
the the testimony and the bill are very
clear this would allow for signature
verification
at least in my interpretation
representative Lane I'm sure you will
refute that
shall out of the sentence does not
change the intent it commands the
moderator to do so in certain success
situations and I think the shell in in
here is Superfluous and I do not think
that it changes the existing statute to
address the court order but I'm not a
judge and will let a judge decide that
spoken like a lawyer a true lawyer a
very good lawyer by the way a very good
lawyer representative on an insult
present Lane's lawyer it's an attorney
my response to that representative Lane
would be if we didn't have to change it
then why did he change it he changed it
for a reason
he changed it for a reason and he
changed it for his testimony to open the
door to signature verification that's
what he said and that's why he's
touching that law nothing else
um
there's no other reason to your point of
being Superfluous there's no other
reason to change it other than to reopen
the door to relitigate it because the
representative where are you recognized
yes thank you Mr chair um yeah I
just the whole transparency thing is is
concerning because I think we've passed
almost unanimous bills this session that
uh provided you know mechanisms for
Clear public observation of events and
and granted at the tail end of the
election process and to
to allow something that then would
remove that at the front end of the
election process is a little bit
disturbing so I think
um
it's hard for me to support something
that
goes against the fundamentals of things
okay representative Lane see this is a
lively one I like this one
I I guess I would like to ask a question
um
about removing the outer envelope in
certain circumstances is that a no-go or
is that something we could work with
was that was that question directed at
the committee okay at the commission
Hall will it representative weary answer
first since he moved towards this
microphone
so in another industry I've done a lot
of data Integrity Audits and chain of
custody is a very important aspect and
by separating the affidavit envelope
from the rest of the vote you're you're
really you're removing an element of the
chain of custody at that point and so I
think that undermines the very aspect
that we would Endeavor to seek for an
election Integrity so
I have concerns about from that
perspective
can you repeat your question
representative Lynn
yes
I was wondering if the fact that we had
no outer envelope
when for some circumstances was that
something that could could be acceptable
or worked around in other words is it
just a flat no-go that we want we
wouldn't be able to solve that by
retaining the bill uh I can speak for
myself personally I cannot speak for the
committee obviously
um I don't have a problem with getting
rid of the outer envelope
um I have a problem with handling
election materials in an unsupervised
way it's not transparent uh and I do and
I know we disagree on this but I like
election day to take place entirely on
Election Day
um barring that I do not I really have
objections with it being handled in an
indefinite period in terms of your
direct question to the outer envelope
I've actually kind of often wondered why
we have another envelope
um because it just seems like something
that you we pay for
um but I don't know once again it's a
yes and a no and I hope I sufficiently
confused you if you're if you're
offering to retain the bill I'm happy to
I'm happy to vote for a retaining motion
but first we'd have to vote on the uh on
the underlying the underlying motion of
inexp to legislate
but you'd have to let me know if you
okay
well we know how we're gonna go on the
Motions
okay if it's the day of caucuses
representative Brennan thank you Mr
chair I
agree that the outer envelope there is a
cost to that if it is not really a
necessary thing for every single
absentee ballot we are paying for outer
envelopes that we don't actually need
and so
um I think there is some room to have
discussions about the necessity of the
outer envelope while maintaining the
Integrity of the ballot and that process
but if I may make a second Point
regarding the signature verification and
the training that was brought up by the
Secretary of State and what they would
be offering it's my understanding that
signature verification training
is intensive and
there was no indication from that I can
recall
from the Secretary of State's office
that they would be providing
the Intensive signature verification
training that would be required
to conduct signature verification
activities for each and every
ballot that is received
there is nothing that I can find in this
bill and please point it out to me if I
have skipped over it that indicates that
training on signature verification
is part of this
so while training has been discussed the
bill itself does not
require the Secretary of State to
conduct any kind of training whatsoever
on signature verification whether it is
compulsory or otherwise
um
I do share the concern that opening the
door for signature verification is not a
door that we
um
but I do not see the language in this
bill
that opens that door
and as has been stated it would be up to
the courts to find that door if it was
cracked open or if it is
entirely shut as the bill does not
indicate
that door will would be opening fair
enough uh representative Burnham
thank you Mr chairman I have a question
since you've had um absentee ballots
sent to your home
yes so the outer envelope does it have
any information indicating that it
there's an absentee ballot in the end in
the envelope
oh I mean it's it's pretty obvious the
outer envelope says the absentee ballot
uh so the outer envelope that you send
in actually says election materials and
the reason why that's important
um is because in 2020 when we had a slew
of absolute ballots well 33 of New
Hampshire voters voters voted with an
absentee ballot
um the U.S Postal Service actually said
we will deliver election materials
without postage on it uh which is a
point that I when we had the postage
bill that came forward I actually
stunned nobody made but I wasn't going
to help
um but the so yes it is clear what's
inside it says election materials
enclosed I believe is what it says on it
um now I'm a little fuzzy on that I've
been voting in person for some time
um but and does the absentee ballot
envelope
say absentee ballot on that envelope it
says election materials yeah which is I
mean a a rational person would gather
you know it's like I wasn't speeding on
93 this morning I was going fast
um I'm just curious because I'm just I'm
assuming that it is done for the
purposes of protecting The Ballot or
having the outer envelope uh I I
believe I I you know I don't know why
we've had the outer envelope before I'm
trying to be honest I don't know why
um I I the only thing that I could kind
of think of it's like it's another layer
of protection like if it gets wet or
something spilled on it
which is certainly with my messy house
it's a possibility
um
well that little well he's not running
yet but he's working on it okay so my
because I have assisted in opening
um ballots on Election Day in public so
we were only told to open the outer
envelope and to uh take the absentee
envelope open it but not to take
anything out that was the process to
help
um with the increase in the absentee
ballot it went very smoothly and quickly
because there were several of us that
were elected officials to do so in
assisting the town clerk I'm just
wondering why
um there would be an outer envelope in
the first place if it doesn't if if it's
not for the protection of the ballot
I think we'd have to speculate I can't
give you definitive answer as to exactly
why it's there and well that's just
that's just what I'm raising there's
there's a reason for that outer envelope
and and really if there's such an
increase like we've seen in 2020 there
are means of assisting the clerk to um
advance that process and there was no
delays well to address the last part
about the increased nasty ballots um the
absolute ballots have largely gone back
to pre-pandemic levels they're still a
little elevated I think it's like two or
three percent but it's not like normally
in a normal New Hampshire election
absolute ballots account for anywhere
from 10 to 15 of the overall vote and
some of that by the way does depend on
the partisanship of the district that it
is voting
um and so you can kind of predict like
what turnout's going to be based on what
absentee ballots look like in terms of
like who's who is a requested one who's
returned the mess ordeal but to your
underlying Point
um we're kind of back down we're like
two or three percent above where we were
2020 was obviously
an irregularity right like a third of
our voters loaded with absentee ballots
and in some locality municipalities
voting locations that that was an over
300 increase right we're not in that so
anyway so if that's I guess my my
statement to you would be if that's part
of your Calculus don't make that part of
your accountants because we're kind of
already moved past that at least the
voters have right so what then what is
the point of the bill yeah that's uh
that's why we're here what is the point
of what is the point of the bill
representative weary just to tack on to
what representative Brennan said is uh
we've heard the Secretary of State's
office testify that even though they
conduct training
it is poorly attended
um by a third of what they would have
anticipated so even if they did provide
signature verification training
extensive in whatever form it is
unlikely that we would have
uh large groups who are properly
trained and educated in that
verification process
okay
um President Obama then I think we're
gonna wrap it up because I think we all
know where we're at here on the itel
motion then we kind of quick caucus and
figure out what we want to do from there
yeah I just wanted to verify uh State
the same it's I believe it's for
protection of the ballot how many of you
have gotten mail that's been opened
I mean just because maybe it wasn't
sealed right or whatnot so I think is
the good protection for that outer
envelope to protect the absentee balance
all right and with that I'm going to
call close to the our very Lively
conversation I did enjoy it um and the
clerk is going to call we are on the
motion of inexpecting the legislate on
Senate Bill 158 uh the cleripaldo
representative Purdue O'Brien yes
representative bogert
yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative lean
no
representative Ward no
representative Hamer no
representative Hamlet no
representative Muirhead
representative Bay no
representative Brennan no
representative Grill no representative
Howard no representative Berry uh I'm
yes
nine to nine
okay
um would you like to caucus briefly okay
you guys you guys take it in here we're
going in there okay all right uh five
minutes uh
uh it shouldn't be yeah we can't I don't
know could you hear us when we were over
here
it wasn't very riveting was it
I don't I don't you can go you can go to
wherever you can take this room and I
can take my guys down to 300 if you want
you wanna do that yeah all right so
okay we will uh we will reconvene we'll
be in recess until it's 11 17 so let's
give us till 11 25. we'll reconvene 11
25. Republicans will join me in my very
so we are now the bill is now open to a
further motion representative Lane
you're recognized for a motion thank you
I'd like to move to retain SB 158 is
there a second to the motion to retain
uh representative Ward uh is a second is
there the discussion on retaining paying
the bill
again there's issues with this bill I
know they're trying to solve some
problems and but I want to make sure
that we do it in a way that the
committee is satisfied
that IT addresses many of the issues
that have been raised and I'd like to
also find out you know why the second
envelope is required and get some
information from the Secretary of State
and work on the language about the um
signature verification so
okay
um further discussion
saying none the clerk will call the roll
representative boom yes
representative purdom O'Brien yes
representative bogert yes
representative Ankerberg no
representative Burnham no
representative Kennedy no
representative weary no
representative wood no
um yes
no I was kidding representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes excuse
representative beerhead
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes representative
Howard
sorry representative Barry yes
that is 13 to 5. okay and with that
house bill 158 is retained
conclosing the executive session on
House Bill 158
opening the executive session on uh
Senate Bill see Simba 158 opening Senate
Mr chair yep uh versus recognized move
itl on Senate Bill 271 okay is there a
second
all second all right the motion is on
inexpension legislate on Senate Bill 271
is there discussion on the bill
representative aikenberger recognized
yeah so we just uh heard the Senate
President address the committee
um he basically
insinuated and told us that this bill is
totally unenforceable so I'm not really
sure what we're doing here so we should
kill it representative how are you
recognized
thank you Mr chairman uh I want to Echo
the points that representative akerberg
just made I think that this is just
something that would clear uh they would
create space in our statutes and we
don't need that so I'm going to be
voting for it
very conservative argument to save Inc
uh represent any other uh anyone else
like to speak to this bill
um I will be joining uh my colleagues in
voting and speech legislate it is
um just as a broader statement about
what's going on with the National
Convention this could be happening to
either party
um the old campaign uh guy in me wants
to sit here and like oh how do you do
this the reality is is
um this could be very well my party
trying to circumvent this process as
well so I guess my message to the
committee
um along this bill along any Bill doing
with first the nation is we need to
explore options that actually have teeth
this is a toothless option
um unconstitutional and God forbid if
the AG actually tried to enforce it I
actually believe it would further erode
our strength in the national uh in the
First Nation primary because it would
establish rights that the parties
currently have that have not been
adjudicated
um it would in it would
um set those in stone so
um we need something that has teeth this
is this isn't it this has no teeth
um and representative bone he recognized
hey just if I remember right over the my
many years
this happened once before with the
Republican Party
and it had come to the end after they
said they wouldn't be seated they voted
to see them so
um I have a long conversation about how
I don't think just not seeing the
delegates is going to be what they do
this time
um this time I think what they're going
to do is what's been I've been talking
about it for six years everybody thinks
I'm crazy and that's okay I think that
what they're going to do this year is
What's called the poison pill Amendment
um which nobody in the New Hampshire
you'll talk about but what they what I
believe they will do and I could be
wrong is they will not seat New
Hampshire's delegates they will say any
candidate who puts their name on our
ballot will not have any delegates and
in that case we would conduct the first
the nation primary
um but there would be nobody running
um so that is what I think what they're
headed to this bill doesn't do that this
bill doesn't solve that problem
um we as a committee need to get
together to figure out how to solve that
problem in the interest of New Hampshire
but that is not going to be what the
party is about to do uh at least what I
believe I have to do would not be
protect our law will not protect us from
what they're going to do because it will
in effect we will have no primary we
will physically conduct the election
there will be no one on the ballot
um with that bombshell uh we will call
the roll
representative boom yes
representative purdom O'Brien yes
representative bogert
yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Brenham yes
representative Kennedy
representative weary yes
representative wood yes representative
lean yes representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Muirhead yeah
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes representative
Howard yes representative Barry yes
18 to zero okay is there a motion for
consent or do we want to debate this on
the floor
[Laughter]
okay and I'll second it okay and with
that we'll put it on the consent
calendar um
and then so with that uh SB 270 will
come out of committees and experience
legislature we're going to close the
executive session on Senate Bill 271 and
we will open the Senate Bill the
executive session on scr1 uh and I'm
looking for a motion
representative how a representative wood
makes a motion yes thank you Mr chair
I'd like to move uh eight eight SRC one
two scr one two uh OTP uh to pass
there's enough to pass motion uh
representative Howard would like to make
the second to that motion I would okay
um is there discussion on the ought to
pass motion
representative wood
um we could discuss about the value of a
resolution all we want
um did get a chance to look at
first in the nation and clearly after
looking at a lot of material last night
there's only one state that can claim it
if I was in charge I'd make sure we
wouldn't lose it nobody else can take it
away from us from what I can see and I
would like to go through the motions and
support any effort that's done along
those lines
for the discussion
um representative thank you Mr chair I
would just point out that uh look at
looking at this resolution we had all 24
members of the senate in support I would
hope that uh
adds to the the Senate president's
sentiments when he came and testified
this morning on 271. this is the
statement in support of the person the
nation primary status for New Hampshire
I think it gives New Hampshire citizens
a voice in a larger National discussion
it's very important that we're
recognized as being first in the nation
I'll support this thank you okay further
comments from the committee
seeing none with clerical cultural
representative boom yes
representative Purdue Bryan yes
representative bogert
yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative weary
yes
representative wood yes
representative Lane
yes
representative Ward
representative Hamer yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Muirhead yes
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes representative
Howard yes representative Berry yes
eighteen to zero excellent consent uh
I'm Gonna Keep It Off consent for right
now I think it's actually to represent
this point about all 24 Senators
supporting it I think it's important
that we have a unanimous vote on this in
the house and that's not on consent
calendar
so I'm going to keep it off consent okay
but no minority no there will be no
minority part but there it will not be
on the consent counter I think this is
um with that I'm going to close the
executive session on scr1
um representative Brennan you are
pointing it I have a I have a point of
order okay yes do we have to vote on the
amendment to 270
270 not 2 271 I'm sorry no because it's
not brought forward okay just checking
nope
we already acted on the bill and it's
nobody nobody felt the need to stand up
for the primary
um
. Oh Yes actually thank you thank you
um we do need to get the committee
reports here
um
so let's go through this real fast uh SB
70 representative Lane I believe that's
your wheelhouse or do you want me to
that's all right I'll take care of it
I'll take I'll take care of sb70 since
it's my Amendment um The Minority Report
representative Burnham I believe you
voted in the negative
can you do the Minority Report for sp70
you don't have to but it's the
opportunity
um sc156 was retained SB 157
representately and I am going to give
you that one
that that horrible consent calendar bill
that's really a lot of lift there
um and then SC SB 271 was another
consent calendar bill I need uh
representative aikenberg is going to do
that and then scr1
[Music]
um
oh you want to do that one all right
please you know what he wins you know
why because he's already done it
so uh if anybody could get me those uh
preferably by the end of the week I
think I'd like to just get this in
um and uh this I do not I was trying to
see I do not believe we have any more
bills I was trying to see I knew that
there was a
the Senate's version of a cacr
um for but I I didn't I have not taken
possession of that bill
um so I don't know if it's coming to us
um so my my hope is that this is the
last time that we're meeting until next
year
um if we do have to get back not that I
don't enjoy seeing all of you
um
well we could do the train bills next
year they're retained
yeah
between the fall sorry yeah yeah we'll
see I'll see you this year we'll see you
in the fall
um
and then um but if we do meet if we do
get that that s that cacr wherever they
call it my intention is to do a snap
hearing a snap hearing and a snap
executive session during lunch while
we're in session my gut is that since
that we have not gotten any
um lengthy testimony about the
presidential primary bills to this date
and we all just took two unanimous votes
that we could probably grind through
that in about five minutes because you
know how I feel about lunch which it is
time for lunch so I will see you all in
the fall and in session uh and maybe uh
maybe one more time
and I believe that the ACR is to put
it down
all right do you need any of the totals